you have kids sure how old are your kids
my daughter is she was born in 68 and my
son was born in 73. how did you raise
your kids religiously religiously I'm
asking
in no way
you didn't you said you're secularly
Jewish but you didn't celebrate Hanukkah
Rosh Hashanah nothing nothing garnished
and did they celebrate Christmas
American holidays well it's inescapable
you celebrate Christmas because you take
off well you said hey by the way we were
Jewish you don't really I think that the
fact that we were Jewish was imprinted
on us vividly by my parents
for the Holocaust by the events of
History there's no escaping that no
desire to escape it either
but in terms of again of a religious
life
not even a suggestion and your kids knew
your parents oh yeah and your parents
fled Germany right at the height of the
holiday fled uh fled Germany in 1932 but
for France okay which was a big mistake
oh right well this must have had some
bearing on your religious views and your
parents religions views you said that
they prayed to the god of music
or you know they believed in the god of
but I know a lot of like I'm Jewish I've
had family grandparents aunts and uncles
that died in the Holocaust and
I always find it there's so many Jews
that say I could never believe in God
again like they killed my entire family
killed everyone I know and there's some
Jews that somehow become more religious
and they cling to that what
you know what affected the Holocaust and
everything that you're from Germany in
the 1940s
your family was there what effect did
that have on your religion and then how
did that trickle down to your kids
because your kid's not having any
religious basis there's got to be
something behind us all together no
you've got to pay more attention to what
I'm saying I didn't say my children have
no religious basis they grew up as Jews
as I grew up they had no religious
education which is quite a different
matter for example they never went to
Temple never went to Temple they had no
bar mitzvah no bar mitzvah I did they
didn't okay you see the you see the
tradition undergoing a gradual
dissolution which I think is
characteristic of the Jewish experience
liberal Judaism
um my parents regarded the Holocaust as
a confirmation of their Jewish identity
my father always said the Nazis taught
me I was a Jew and he was right
but that doesn't mean he rediscovered a
religious faith that meant he
rediscovered the fact that he was a Jew
my mother was a Jew the family was
Jewish culturally
far more than culturally being Jewish is
not a cultural phenomenon not at least
it's more than that it's a deep
continuity of historical experience and
historical memory
my grandfather perished now schwitz my
mother never got over that and uh
nonetheless
my parents effort I've been talking
about my parents effort to give me a
religious education didn't succeed I did
have a bar mitzvah I still remember my
bar mitzvah prayers
but uh the sad truth of the matter is I
found it all excruciatingly boring and I
still do I can attest to that I'm not
about to spend a whole lot of time in
the temple
what are your kids now what are their
faith now or are they practicing or
they're similar to you we're all secular
all secular deeply secular and we have
all of the vices but all of the virtues
of a secular identity that is we all
in some way believe that we're
self-created that the most important
thing in our lives collectively is the
autonomy of personality
that the personality exists in order to
be satisfied that our desires have an
intrinsic value that are quite
independent of what other people believe
I think both my children and I certainly
appreciate the fact that to achieve
certain things this is a great deal of
discipline involved I'm not talking
about hedonism
uh the desire to lead a life such that
you're having a good time all the time I
I don't think anyone believes in that I
live in South Beach there might be some
people that disagree with you
uh South Beach Florida I guess yes yes
certainly there are people prepare to
say it
but I know very few people very few
satisfied headedness over the age of 30.
um the Declaration that you live to have
a good time all the time it becomes very
wearing after a while
but secularism imposes some severe
restraints on how you live
I mean you cannot rely to an extent to
the extent that it was possible to rely
say on the 17th or early 18th century on
institutional authorities
that at every step of the way guide your
footsteps
secularism is the prospect of allowing
human beings to create themselves Anew
in each generation there's no question
about that
and sometimes it's very difficult
sometimes it's painful sometimes it's
exhilarating but as far as I can see we
are all in the position of someone
in a Lifeboat
wondering whether it would be
more practicable to sail the seas in an
ocean liner well we don't have an ocean
liner anymore we've got the Lifeboat
secularism if you will
and that has to uh that has to be enough
we're always in the process of fiddling
with a Lifeboat changing the orlocks
wondering whether we should be sitting
in the front or in the back but
fundamentally we don't have access to an
ocean line that Majestic ocean liner of
faith that has pretty much disappeared
do you envy people of Faith No
and why is that what should I envy them
for so what do you think comes after
life
I have no idea and no idea and not even
something you've thought about utk the
body breaks down it's gone because some
say no no I'm not committing myself to a
view
that uh there is no possibility of
experience after death I have no
privileged insight into that no one else
does either
certainly the fact that every single
Society in recorded history has had some
sort of some form of intense speculation
about the afterlife is significant
because it's a deeply a deeply uh
essential part of human nature to
entertain those convictions
uh but again
all I can say is
I'll know soon enough
please come back and visit us I sure
will you've got to give me your portable
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]